Game of Thrones is home to plenty of
moments that require viewers to put
aside some of their logic in reason
especially when it comes to injuries
after characters like Khal Drogo die of
afflictions like blood poisoning you'd
think that a serious injury might take a
character down once in a while both
Jaime and Arya endure brutal stab wounds
to the stomach during fights Arya loses
a tussle with the wave in season six
while Jaime struggles against euron
Greyjoy in the final season and yet
neither person seems much troubled by
these Grievous injuries Jaime makes it
into the red keep to find Cersei while
Arya somehow leaps into a canal swims
across braavos and is eventually cured
by a cup of soup and a good night's
sleep armor can be effective against
knives but apparently being a series
regular can save you from multiple
stomach wounds as well